Hello and welcome to this is not how I normally look
It's allergy season.
I have a little bit of overcompensation happening.
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know your life is different now.
It's my knee here, my hand's on it.
It's just this weird hovering skin thing.
Looks like a rogue scrotum.
I wrote them.
Anyway,
there's a huge emphasis on self-care right now
which I highly applaud
I think it's important.
You guys know I've taken some time off here and there
in an effort to figure out what is self-care for me,
because it's different for everyone.
Videos about morning routines, night time routines are so interesting to people,
they just want to see what other people do.
Make them seemingly good.
And I thought I recently turned 34, you know
I beat Jesus.
I feel like I
live a
leisurely haggard life.
It's not negative, that's just how I see it.
Especially when I come back from traveling.
And this past weekend I went away for my birthday.
I went to Vegas for two nights
and then I went glamping for a couple nights.
It was a very exhausting experience.
Because when I travel and I go somewhere I get too excited
and then I push my body to the extreme.
When I have to come back to reality I am mad at everything
because I know I did to myself but it's way easier
to take it out on everything else around me.
I thought I'd show you a video about how
I bounce back from travel.
It's sort of like a morning routine,
it's sort of like a hangover routine.
What do you call a bowel movement during a morning routine video?
A Poo-tine.
So already this is like very charming and relatable as video.
Most of this might seem like a joke, but I'm telling you.
This is a very accurate morning routine
Basically, this is how I bounce back.
And also this is just what I do mostly every morning
when I haven't traveled the day before.
Let's get into it!
Obviously I wake up
in a state of
bright-eyed
bushy-tailed confusion
most of the time.
Because regardless of travels
I mostly wake up not knowing like where I am.
And then occasionally I have to check if my dog is alive
'coz sometimes she likes to sleep like
she's been taxidermied
and it scares the actual sh*t out of me.
And when I'm coming back from traveling I've started to
make more of a point to unpack sooner rather than later,
because otherwise
it will just sit in my house
like this bag
that becomes like this tumor that I don't deal with.
And then when I have to repack for a new travel scenario,
I just get so mad at previous self for not
taking five seconds to start unpacking the bag.
There's a lot of symbolism.
Then like a lot of people,
I like to center myself with my form of meditation.
TV: I never though I would be in South Korea
TV: in an government building
TV: getting married to a man I barely know.
YIKES!
Then I like to take a second to stand outside
with a camera on me recording me to like falsely
capture me contemplating life and what it all means.
And then I look at my devil device
and I start comparing myself to the other curated wonderful lives
of the people around me and I feel like a real deep sense of darkness.
And then I put some food in my system.
Thankfully in LA we've access to really quick easy meals.
I already ate it.
Sorry, didn't film it.
And then I tidy up
because as an adult I've learned if you don't
you get ants.
I mean that's kind of across the board,
like if you don't keep it clean,
like you're gonna get some kind of infestation.
Your brain.
Your kitchen.
Your cooter.
And then I jump back on my devil device and I just like
continuously fall down the dark hole of seeing
how great everyone else's lives look
and like how did they get those filters?
Who's taking those photos?
I'm happy for them.
They seem happy and so I'm happy for them and everything.
Oh and then I take a shower.
And then I go back outside and I just think it like
does everyone sh*t like that in the morning?
And then I take my vitamins.
And you're gonna think this is like a shoehorned in sponsorship,
it was at first,
but now this has genuinely become an actual everyday part of my
what we call routine.
Care/of is a company that makes it like way easier to get
vitamins and supplements and protein powders that are
customized to exactly like what you want for your body.
We all start resolutions at the beginning of the year in January
but like fall I feel like is the time when we're all dust off
the shame that we've had for not keeping those resolutions
and now we can start new.
So you basically go on their website.
You take like a five minute quiz.
You answer questions about your diet, your lifestyle, your goals,
and then based on your answers
they come back to you with scientifically backed
recommendations of vitamins, supplements
protein powders etc.
And they will send them to you in a very cute box that is
personalized just for you in tiny cute packets that have your name on them
and have a little quote that might be Inspirational and helpful to you
because what else do you gonna do?
Stare at your devil device?
It gives you at least 30 seconds away from your devil device.
I've become obsessed with these.
I don't know if you've seen how much longer my hair has grown
in the last couple of months but I really think it's because
I have a vitamin in here
that's specifically to help my hair grow.
They also have vegan and vegetarian supplements
so there is truly something for everyone.
They give me this little pamphlet that explains
all of them to me if I
if I
decide to read one day.
I don't want this to sound like I'm feeding you bullsh*t
'coz this is a company I actually truly support and I've become very
dependent on.
This is maybe the healthiest routine I actually have.
And because they've sponsored this video,
obviously,
you can get 25% off your first purchase
Voice over Grace: actually scratch that,
they've decided to give you guys
50% off your first purchase.
That's 5
50%
Holy sh*t
by going to TakeCareOf.com
and using the promo code graceh
Again going to TakeCareOf.com
I love you. You don't have to say it back.
I'll just internalize it.
I'll just look at Instagram and I'll forget all about it.
And then I do my hair makeup
and it's a really swell time.
Ooowwww
F*ck
Me
Then I get back on my phone
and I let like the whole overwhelm of everyone around me
that's seemingly living a much better more fulfilling life
I'd really get right into my phone
so I can just sort of like grow
and like blossom into
wildly unhealthy thoughts.
Well, there you go!
There's my morning routine/my hangover routine/
my like coming back from traveling
getting back into a productive work week routine.
If you guys enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up.
Let me know in the comments down below,
what is part of your morning
hangover
bounce-back get ready for the week routine.
Do you have a routine?
Other than that?
I don't know
Sorry I just got distracted staring at a tree and
we're back